Film Courage: When have you been the most
scared in your career?
Dale Stelly, Filmmaker (COMPTON’S FINEST,
SINGLE BLACK FEMALE and more): It’s scary
when you are dealing with people’s dreams
and stuff and you are not able to make their
dreams come totally true or what have you.
You’re dealing with a lot of dreamers out
here in LA.
My whole thing is I like to help people as
people helped me, you know what I mean?
But a lot of people dream big and it’s like
sometimes people dream bigger than what they
can actually accomplish which is nothing wrong
with it but I hate…not hate…but dislike
when you set a goal to work with people or
situations and it doesn’t go in a direction
that you expected and that can be kind of
disheartening sometimes because you put your
heart and energy in productions.
And it’s just like having a baby and then
certain things can go wrong during the pregnancy.
You might break up with the husband or cheated
on you while you are pregnant or something.
That’s what I’m saying, like a movie production
things can go wrong like that with a pregnancy
and the energy is all off.
So I like to be part of productions even though
there is no money or little money or whatever
but everyone is positive or sticking to the
goal until we finish.
I usually (90% of the time) take on projects
that I know I can actually bring to fruition
and to life.
There are sometimes when you tackle some things
and some things are not meant to be even though
you are putting your whole heart and passion
and resources and running every single play
that you can to make it a successful production.
But some things are not meant to be and I
found out during the course of my career not
everybody is meant to be helped out, you know
what I mean?
I found out the hard way that sometimes certain
people want to take advantage of you and they
will say certain things to get you to help
them.
And once you help them, they flip the script
on you.
And it’s kind of like “Arrghh!”
I just give everyone the benefit of the doubt.
And it is always great when a project is green
lit or what have you?
But sometimes people see things that are not
there yet and me I’m always like let’s
finish the product before you start thinking
about dollars or deals or whatever.
But you can’t control people’s expectations
or the way they feel.
And I know these cameras and actors and lights,
it comes with certain expectations.
And certain things comes with this territory
that you just have to know how to deal with.
Film Courage: I had someone I knew who read
Andy Warhol’s biography and this person
was telling me that certain people loved him
but other people were mad at him because they
were like “No…you were supposed to make
me famous.”
Even thought that wasn’t necessarily the
agreement, that’s what they thought.
And so that is a reality of what happens in
this town, whatever you’re doing somebody
could think “Well you didn’t help me become
famous and I was supposed to become famous.”
Dale: Right.
My thing is I don’t put my career in nobody’s
hands, you know what I mean?
I try to be responsible for my own success.
When you rely on other people do be successful
that’s not the route to go.
The road to go is do whatever it takes and
if that’s in yourself and all your hard
energy and your goals and at the same time
you can help other people with the common
goals and it goes back and forth but it takes
a lot of energy to make this all come to life.
Film Courage: There is this one quote and
I think it’s from a female musician [Patti
Smyth] and she says just keep your name clean
and good.
And I think that’s great, a lot of people
have honorable intentions but sometimes you
can’t help if the other person gets mad
and it’s not something that you did.
Dale: Yes, right.
Like I said I’m not perfect.
I don’t think anyone is perfect.
And everyone goes into situations with a common
goal which is whatever the goal is, let’s
get it done.
But with creativity and the creative process
and everyone being individuals and everyone
being responsible for certain things to happen
so other things can happen, some times things
don’t go right and sometimes people do get
mad and sometimes people do not understand
what you were doing for them in the beginning.
It can turn into a headache, things can turn
into headache.
But my thing is what puts away the headaches
at the end of the day is when the product
eventually gets completed and it comes out,
you know what I mean?
I’ve been on productions a couple of times
where people wanted to hurt people and stuff.
And at the end of the day when the movie comes
out and everything and it came out through
Sony and the way it was supposed to, people
forgot about the arguments and wanting to
fight on set and things of that nature.
But nothing is perfect and that’s why I
stay prayed-up as much as I can and pray for
successful situations even if it goes wrong,
figure out how to get it back on track and
I don’t like to be part of negative situations
because it’s already hard enough whatever
the goal is already.
If it wasn’t hard it would already be done
or it would already be financed or it would
already be done with (with a bigger situation)
so to me I’m always like an underdog compared
to these other studios.
I know exactly what to do and these other
studios and everything but I don’t have
the manpower or the money behind me.
It might take me longer to figure it out but
I can eventually figure out whatever the goal
is or task is.
It’s just a matter of time.
In this business, money pays for things to
get done faster, you know what I mean?
So on that note, it’s knowing how to use
your time and money effectively and everything
eventually gets done.